oui qu'est ce qu'il a dit il va détruire
le monde
cela ne peut-il être invité y'en a
corrompu ce monde et l'a empli de
violence nous devons disparaître
un grand élu j'approche nous allons
construire une arche pour accueillir il
me semble
qu'est ce qu'il ya
qu'est ce que tu veux tu pensais
vraiment que tu pouvais te protéger de
moi là dedans ce n'est pas de toit que
sa protégée
j'ai des hommes avec moi et toi tu es
seul et tu le défi je ne suis pas seul
quand ils viendront
ils sont prêts à tout et il sera mon
rôle
les serpents est aussi tout ce qui
rentre tout ce qui glisse
il t'a choisi pour une raison aux noës
cision est entre tes mains oui
ça commence
non